to find the cost function each iteration of these operators is called a layer these layers can be seen as
discretizations of the time evolution of the system as previously described the alternating pattern comes from the
Trotter decomposition and approximates the exponential functions of non-commuting matrices in general the more layers or
steps we include the closer we will be to continuous time Evolution so in theory the more accurate the result will
be but for this example we'll Begin by just sampling with two layers remember both the cost function hamiltonian and
the mixer are parameterized we still need to come up with Optimum values for gamma and
beta now I recognized that was a lot of information and if you're seeing this type of math for the first time it can be tricky luckily one of the awesome
things about kiss kit is that a lot of what we just went over can be done automatically without a huge lift from the user it's good to understand what's
going on under the hood especially as we scale up to bigger experiments but you won't have to do all of this work by
hand every single time we have now mapped our problem onto a Quantum circuit it was a bit of work
but don't worry it becomes easier and more intuitive the more you do it now we're ready to move on to step two
optimizing our circuit for Hardware so while the circuit we just created look looks pretty simple and is
useful to build up an intuitive understanding remember the quantum chip doesn't understand what this abstracted
block is we need to turn it into a series of one and two Cupid Gates that are native to the hardware and when I
say native I mean it will be refactored into what's able to be performed directly on the cubits such circuits are
said to be written in the back ends instruction set architecture which you might see abbreviated as Isa circuits
the kcit SDK transpiler module offers a series of transpilation passes that can
perform a wide range of circuit Transformations we want to make sure that our circuit is optimized for our
purpose recall from our previous lesson that the transpilation and process involves several steps mapping the
cubits in the circuit or the decision variables to physical cubits on the device unrolling of the instructions in
the quantum circuit to the hardware native instructions that the back end actually understands routing of any
cubits in the circuit that directly interact to physical cubits that are adjacent with one
another and as always more details about this can be found on the documentation
site now comes an exciting step where we'll choose which backend to run our circuit on we actually have to do this
before the transpilation step because the transpiler optimizes differently for different processor this is yet another reason why it's
important that kkit can automate so much of this stage away you wouldn't want to have to optimize your circuit by hand
which can be done but sometimes It's Tricky and very timec consuming only to realize that you actually want to run
your circuit on a different processor with different properties and then you have to do all of that work again pass
your back end of choice through the transpiler function and don't forget to specify your optimization level this
time I've selected optimization level three which is the highest and most exhaustive omanization
level and that's actually it for step two my circuit was transpiled automatically and I drew it here so that
you can see how it was translated into one and two Cubit Gates now it is time for step three
running the circuit with kcit Primitives so far we transpiled the circuit leaving the parameters gamma and
beta alone but we can't actually run the circuit without specifying the value of the these parameters in the qaoa
workflow the optimal qaoa parameters are found in an iterative optimization Loop where we run a series of circuit
evaluations and use a classical Optimizer to find the optimal beta and gamma parameters however we need to start
somewhere so I have implemented some initial guesses for Gamma 1 gamma 2 and beta 1 beta 2 of Pi / 2 and Pi
respectively I also want you to note that we will be using an optimizer to find better solutions for gamma and Beta
And since I'm only calculating two layers for now that's all I need but if you make a more accurate qaoa circuit
you would include more layers and thus need an optimized gamma and beta for each sequential
layer now let's just take a minute here to pause and remember our options for The Primitives we have the estimator and
the sampler which one do you think that we are going to be using for this type of job well no matter which one you
guessed you're actually correct we are going to use both the estimator and the sampler for the initial optimization
Loop we will need the estimator but we'll use the sampler later on for reading out the final
solution now we are almost ready to run our algorithm I promise but very quickly it is important to note that you can
send your job a variety of different ways which are called execution modes first we have job mode a single
primitive request of the Ator or sampler made without a context manager circuits and inputs are packaged as primitive
unified blocks pubs and submitted as an execution task on the quantum
computer batch mode is a multi-job manager for efficiently running an experiment that is comprised of a bunch
of independent jobs use batch mode to submit multiple primitive jobs simultaneously session mode a dedicated
window for running a multi job workload this allows premium users to experiment with variational algorithms in a more
predictable way and even run multiple experiments simultaneously taking advantage of the parallelism of the
stack use sessions for iterative workflows and experiments that require dedicated access for a qaa experiment a
session would be a good choice to proceed with if you have access to it since you'll need to try multiple circuits for different values of beta
and gamma okay now let's go back to our optimization problem we have already
defined the cost function hamiltonian HC and the full workflow is this the qaoa
algorithm starts by initializing the cubits in the superposition State and then applies the onot with P layers it
initializes gamma and beta parameters and then run the circuit using the estimator primitive once we calculate
the expectation values we will then use a scipi Optimizer called Coba Coba
optimizes the cost function classically outside of the qpu once those values of gamma and beta have been updated we
repeat we will do this until the value of the overall cost function has converged and reached the lowest value